and on the mound today is will crow as
we continue to try and watch some of
these younger pitchers develop hopefully
today he ends august on a high note 3-1
pitch
and that's taken low so a two out walk
and it brings in nolan aronado o'neal
the runner at first and that backs up
for a ball back to back walks which was
a problem in the big game that the
cardinals had last night for the pirates
as their relievers just couldn't find
the strike zone
he struck him out with a fastball took a
while but crowe puts up a zero and the
pirates will come to bat 19 starts this
year for kim back in the rotation after
the injury to jack polarity so the lefty
will get the pirates here today
and a four pitch walk to him that's
amazing how about ball four is on a
breaking ball and the next to moran
lifted in the air to center backing up
harrison bader
with room right near that 399 marker in
center pirate strand a runner and
there's no score
and that'll help into right and that
ball is down yoshi over to cut it off
carlson is going to test him throw into
second not in time safe they're going to
run on yoshi all day the over slide is
is going to be in question here
they're going to challenge it
and they're going to overturn this one
in a
in a new york second
second that's good bob
2-2 pitch
stallings
back to kk
and the first out here in the home half
of the second
got him
pitch on the outside corner kim his
first strikeout
another 2-2 and a swing and a miss
struck him out
a fastball at 95 one out
one-two pitch
and he drives it into the gap in right
center
and it's off the base of the wall
he'll trot into second base with double
number 35. well there you go just just
another double for edna crow looks at
the runner and delivers swinging a miss
he struck him out he threw the fastball
by him he strikes out goldschmidt for
the second out so it's up to uh tyler
o'neill if the cardinals are going to
score this in it and he lifts a fly ball
into deep right field tsutsugo back and
it's off the wall a run will score
that's tommy edmond
and tyler o'neal will wind up with
another st louis triple in this series
one nothing cardinals here in the top of
the third
2-2 pitch
got him
pulled the string in a strikeout number
two today for the cardinal lefty if i'm
a right-handed hitter against kk i'm
setting my sights on the outer half he
likes to cut everything out there sink
out there oh my goodness what a catch by
harrison bader in left
center and the reaction of kim says it
all
that was fantastic here you see him dive
when he first dove i thought did he dive
too soon but he knew exactly what he was
doing
great full layout there makes the play
holds on to it with a catch
here's the 1-0
carlson on a delayed steal he's going to
be hung out to dry tucker running him
back to first and moran
will tag him out as he went out of the
baseline
is a caught stealing
two to four to three
and on the other hand vader though he
does great work with the glove against
the pirates really struggles at the
plate has just four hits and 21 at bats
on this home stand
and now has a
hit to start the bottom of the fourth
oh they said first and second another
hayes hit right yeah just identical
right through the hole
and a base hit to right hayes had to
freeze the bases are loaded
three straight singles
see the pirates can't have another
seventh inning like they had on thursday
got him
so the first out is strikeout as
stallings
that's me looked like he was really
trying to protect in he he didn't want
to get beat in and get jammed here is
sutsugo
the other way to left and
catch is going to be made by o'neal
runner at third tags and will score
hayes comes across to tie it
on the sacrifice fly by tsutsugo it's
1-1
cole struck out his first time up and
the 2-1 pitch ground ball to short
horseplay at second
so base is loaded and nobody out and the
pirates get one they tie it up and we
move to the fifth
making them work here the 3-2
good at bat draws a walk great at bet
tommy edmond is up 3-1 pitch
and he lifts a high fly ball into deep
right center
tommy edmond
what a series he's had it's a double
today and now a two-run homer in his
second home run in the series cardinals
back on top
and the pitch
down low nope got him perfectly placed
down and away for strike three
2-0 pitch and that's a base hit into
right field
so carlson on base
for the third time today
so the cardinals now with something
going with one out here in the sixth
inning
six
four
got him
oh no it looked like i had him
i want to see the replay on that one
he's off the back here isn't he
originally oh no his foot
foot is on the back
they're gonna lose that challenge and
they should then should be a double play
right could be because this ball is
watch you can see it in the glove
now
what do we have here i don't know out
out at first so that's a double play
yeah that's it
and the pitch tucker takes down low ball
forward now he draws the walk
next pitch is a swing and a miss he
struck him out another terrific
performance by t.j mcfarland
oh what a play here from his knees god
on the stretch at first by goldie one of
the most remarkable plays you'll see on
both ends
oh my goodness
play of the game
nolan orinato
[Applause]
not only that but the speed of defo he
can fly aronado had to get rid of it
quickly didn't even have time to get to
his feet throws it from his knees
what a play all the way around
nobody out here leading off the inning
the 3-2 pitch that's down low and
reynolds will take the walk
the tying runs going to come up
here's a 3-2 down low ball for another
walk
the pirates have the tying runs aboard
for yoshi tsutsugo
live ball to right field did he do it
yoshi
tsugio
[Applause]
unbelievable
for three bucks
what an impact that guy has made on this
team and it's such a short time